hi and welcome to episode number 47 of
the weekly Google platform podcast i am
princess can point i'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks francisc how
you doing we're in a slightly different
room today yeah I think I think people
will be able to hear a little bit of the
echo unless you are you doing an amazing
job that's a good eating that's unlikely
yeah so probably it's Omega and that is
because yeah someone broke tour in our
studio so we cannot enter yep things
happen that's fine anyway so today we're
going to be interviewing two people from
the cloud abuse team swati cool shred
and make our Konko i hope i didn't
completely mispronounce your name and
they're gonna be telling us about what
is cloud abused why you should care and
basically how cloud views is here to
protect you also yeah I think this was
this is really kind of cool it is it is
a really interesting conversation and
why you should care as a customer of gcp
about what this group exists it's not
there to get in your way it so that it
really help you yeah you know actually
is also to protect people outside of
glove go plop plop onto which is an
interesting thing yeah after that we
have our question of the week where we
go back to communities one of my
favorite topics where we look at easy
ways to deploy like well-known
applications yeah so it's basically like
a mix of your two favorite topics like
deployment manager in communities is
there such a thing yeah so very
interesting and before that we're gonna
go with the cool thing of the week yeah
things things of the week and we have
like for today two of them are really
tiny but so the first one is about data
set new data set available on Google
Cloud which is a public jail geo data
set so basically a bunch of images from
all around the world and if you've
listened to all our episodes this might
sound familiar it is actually the same
data said that the cath lab which the
cap labs which we interviewed in episode
41 is has been using for quite a while
there's a bunch of images the really
cool actually I I know in the blog post
which will link from the
from the show note there's a bunch of
images that we even used in some help
the show that's for a visit 41 and some
really nice pictures of Australia ah
well as long as it's Australia that's
how it's important yeah it's a place
called Brisbane no no everything Trina's
manner no I know but I mean there had
lost it no looks like there and there's
nice beaches yeah there is and speaking
of open data sets there's another open
data set that I think is also really
cool the open images data set so there's
a consists of like over or approximately
nine million URLs two images that have
been annotated with the labels spanning
about what is it six thousand categories
so if you want to get sort of some
images data that you want to put through
machine learning and tag it very similar
to see how like Google photos or the
cloud vision API works you can do that
so you could actually do some really
neat stuff with it yeah i think that
basically if you have all of these
pictures with all the annotations and
then you want to get like start playing
wii with tensorflow this could be a
really nice place to basically can you
try to emulate the cloud vision API yeah
I actually think it could be cool as
well in the like you could dig into like
specific categories of stuff like say
you want to be able to work out say what
metal maybe cutler is made out of so you
grab everything that is cutlery and then
kind of break it down from there you
could do some really interesting stuff
as like a starting point from which I'm
actually seeing the picture of the color
ii and have no idea what metal that is i
don't know that's why i saw the image
doing kind of a good point yeah but like
something something like that could be
really interesting yeah that sounds that
sounds like something I could try I'm
and then there's two more cool things on
the week which are completely self
promotion so I'm shameless yeah so
France ask if you've had a podcast in
theory and you wanted to get that
podcast to go onto YouTube how would you
do such a thing it's a very interesting
? so we actually did this as we
announced a couple weeks ago we actually
have all of our podcast episodes
available on YouTube and this was done
automatically because it is easier well
it's actually not easier but I do not
hate my life so basically what what this
does is it's a docker container that
will download
thing some files mp3 files from an RSS
feed and publish everything to YouTube
adding one image that you can choose and
then is that it just it just has been
open source so you can go to github com
/ kappa / podcaster youtube and just
check it out and then i also open source
something else last week which is a go
web workshop it's called NH basically
the basics on how to build web
applications using go on App Engine so
if you're curious about to learn how I
normally do it it's on the front and
side of things it's super light so don't
expect to learn anything about css3 or
html5 it is it is actually pretty bad
but so we don't care because these about
the back end so you will learn about how
to use datastore and memcache and how to
send emails and stuff like that awesome
sounds great well why don't we have a
chat with sweaty and emeka and talk to
them about Clara be cool let's do that
so I'm very happy to welcome to the
podcast to members of the cloud abuse
team so we have a sweaty clothes fresh
hi how are you doing hi and ma khong co
hi pleasure to meet you how are you
about doing good good yeah nice to meet
you guys well done Francesca those are
cute yorkie names I know there's this
mess specialty for but then I mess it up
with completely English sounding names
so why don't you why don't we start
talking a little bit about who you are
what do you do I google maybe start with
us watching mm-hmm sure i'm part of the
cloud trust and safety team and I what
our team does is basically protect the
cloud from abuse originating from google
cloud i specifically look at the
developer experience associated with
that and i work as a senior strategist
on the same team and again the mission
is to like protect folks from against
abuse from cloud ok cool so all right we
said abuse a few times through that what
does cloud abuse actually mean like when
you go first sure so cloud abuse as the
way is defined is any kind of activity
that ends up violating the cloud terms
of services or equitable user policy
so our team's goal or mission is to
basically enforce the relevant sections
of the cloud terms of services / AUP
could you give a couple examples of what
kind of terms of services you normally
handle sure so thin such as like denial
of service attacks that emanate from the
cloud platform or intrusion attacks or
even like malware or fishing you know
cause kind of activities are dealing
that we are responsible for like
protecting or preventing and after that
the things like that would violate the
Terms of Service like you're going
beyond your quota restrictions or doing
things that you shouldn't be doing given
the cloud services that you are using
cool and so you're saying that basically
what you're doing is not protecting
Google cloud platform customers from
external views but actually stopping
abuse coming from google cloud platform
that is exactly right our team is
focused on looking at abuse that
originated from the Google cloud
platform and that is the kind of
activity that we specifically look for
and try to stop attack that come to
Google is handled by a site reliability
engineers so that's a different team
yeah we've we've talked with a couple of
them we should keep on talking with more
of that yeah they're always so cool to
talk to okay so like clearly the people
who listen to our podcasts like they're
responsible people they're wonderful
people we love them dearly they're
listener so yeah listener is so clearly
they're great they're not going to
actively go out and try and do things
that are malicious and if arias or
something like that like why should they
care about like cloud abuses they're
like issues in terms of resources or
like what sort of problems is kind of
solving for people who are customers or
g zp so the two types of abuse we see
from coming from google cloud there's
intentional abuse and clearly like i
said your listeners are not one of those
but then there is an unintentional abuse
you did not want to be conducting denial
of service attempts or intrusion items
but your system has been hacked or this
software that you download it and that
is doing it on your behalf and those are
the kinds of things that we are looking
for and those are the kind of things
that you should be looking at two and to
add on to that it could be possible that
for example if someone like hacks your
system so
again that's a breach on your system you
really don't want to be responsible for
that or at least you want to find out as
soon as possible if that happens or if
so what is like making using your
machine to like perform a denial of
service attack that could cost a lot of
money on the cloud and so a lot of
computing resources that you would have
to be responsible for paying for so
hopefully if we catch that in time that
would be very awesome for you and also
finally if you're the if you have an
external website that is you know hosted
somewhere we are trying to protect you
from being hit by people who are on
cloud so you know makes it life better
for everybody cool and anchor so you
mentioned denial of service attacks what
other kind of use cases don't normally
see like is it people getting infected
with like some parts or but what what
kind of problem they get on my handle
yeah so we see a lot of like Dean
elephant attack we also see a lot of
like a brute force in activities so
basically someone's machine maybe it's
hacked because of course none of our
users are going to do it so a compromise
machine could be trying to like probe
vulnerabilities against external
networks so trying to like maybe find
out like frontal log in to those
networks or even like vulnerability
scanning to like see what's what's easy
to be like polymn prey one of the things
we saw recently or sometime back was
when WordPress had like some
vulnerabilities and it's a shared
security Ballentine we saw a lot of
attacks from google targeting like Ted
parties wordpress sites and or even
people hard-hitting you know the other
cloud people customers world WordPress
so there's kind of a teaser examples I
think one of the things we see very
frequently is that your firewalls have
not been set up properly and then
somebody manages to get into your system
and start doing light the denial of
service attacks approved for saying gosh
any of the other suspicious activities I
guess that means yeah like if I'm
running my service on Google cloud
platform and someone's hacked me then
suddenly I don't have those resources on
that machine available to me anymore if
someone's trying to mine bitcoins or or
whatever it is the cool kids are doing
these days you know suddenly my CP
dogecoins yeah yeah yeah exactly like my
cpu suddenly one hundred percent and so
I can't serve traffic or do anything I
should be doing on my app right and even
like you said so they could be
you have legitimate users who are using
the platform properly but because the
resources are being used by these
irresponsible people or by people who
have been compromised they don't have
the ability to actually enjoy what they
paid for that was a bad experience for
other customers who are not doing abuse
so most of the things that we've
discussed so far are basically people
attacking or somehow compromising the
account of someone that is
well-intentioned does it also happen
that someone is well-intentioned but
somehow they are not aware of some
limitations what but kind of limitations
people sometimes forget I think the
biggest one that we see in this category
is people going outside of the quota
requite are available to them and using
it multiple times so associated with the
free trial there is there are specific
quote I limitations in terms of number
of projects in terms of how many emails
you can send how much network you can
use and that is the one that people
often end up circumventing and then
getting caught by one of our rules you
do try to give a lot of benefit of doubt
so unless you're really egregiously
violating that yeah we probably not come
after you cool and also for example what
we see as well in a gentle what's what
he had mentioned is that a lot of people
may not necessarily like taken the
precaution of securing that instances so
often have the appropriate firewalls to
only allow the traffic from the
designated VMs or instances so what
happens is that someone may basically
kind of hack into that system and use
that systems to as a part of the bots to
do something bad so not taking the
dinner the extra couple of minutes
required to actually look down your
machine to make sure you only get
traffic to and fro from what you really
want to has been a lot of a concern
you're talking a little bit as well just
about like accidental stuff people do
you talk a little bit our project so
there are other any other sort of things
that people often sort of go oh it'll be
fine or they don't even realize that
that was a Terms of Service thing like
that they go past that people should be
aware of the most frequent ones are the
quarters and is like the number of
projects yep and
email gordas yeah and also some
sometimes some people may use the
platform as a hosting provider so that
basically other people can you know run
off of them as a part of the services
they offer to their own customers so if
they don't properly monitor those
customers or kind of like you know check
that traffic they could also like end up
getting a violation about temple
services so for example if they open up
that service to host like uploaded
images some of them may be you know
malware which is now being served from
the cloud customer to extend out people
so again that's also a violation so it
may be not new pacifically but the
people that you provide services to
could end up costing you a violation so
basically any yeah that makes sense
anyway you've got a system that has like
user-generated content or anything like
that you need to be very careful about
what content they're they're putting up
there and what it's possible and able to
do on your platform that's correct cool
so let's imagine that at some point for
some reason either because by mistake
and pay attention to Theresa my service
so somehow I got hot I get an email and
fame is basically saying hey you're
you're we detected some fraudulent
activity in your account what's next
what do I have to do so I can take that
one we when we see something suspicious
we will send out an email to you saying
we seeing the suspicious activity please
check it please get back to us send an
appeal and there'll be a three-day
warning period the thing you need to
keep in mind is that this email goes out
to the project owners so definitely
monitor your project owner email be sure
a lot of developers coming back to us
saying hey I wasn't monitoring it so I
didn't realize that there's something
going on I've heard stories about that
yeah it I think that's a great takeaway
I just wanted like highlight that it's
happened to us actually where we got an
email for our internal email the Google
cloud platform podcast project about
yeah some certificate going away and
we're like whoops so how about that yeah
so yeah it's okay that's a very
important point pay attention to the
email yep so the process going forward
is equal to the developer console there
it will take you to the appeals page and
you
send an appeal the good thing to do
about the appeal is to actually give us
some context around what you are doing
what your project is doing and why do
you think that suspicious activity might
be happening we definitely don't need
the code of your program we don't need a
design diagram but we do need some
context to see why this was happening so
how much information do you give up this
like it will it be some things like oh
you're going over the quote on this or
you are using too much cpu or something
like that or it's just like hey you're
like what what kind of information do
again we definitely provide information
on what kind of suspicious activity
being so we will tell you this is the
kind of bit severe Singh denial of
service attack so we're seeing you so
commanding quota we will give you the
project ID the project name and the time
on which that happened if you need more
information you can definitely write
back to us and sometimes we can help you
out sometimes you need to go back and
look at your own traffic logs and see
what was happening around that time so
it sounds like okay I get the email
which I'm monitoring because I look at
my emails and you'll give me some
information so it really says like a
first step is actually for me to go and
have a look at my project and see if I
can work out what's going wrong and
maybe I need to lock something down
better or just stop doing something that
I probably shouldn't be doing in the
first place that's right and also we
suffice the stable notifications in the
developer console so you can't really
login to your developer console and see
the same information so at least you
will see a notification next to your
project with some icon or something
which you can mouse-over I give you like
more information about like what you
know a high level haircut before we saw
something wrong can you please take a
look it needs your attention so that's
another way that you also get the
information about to water make I just
said if you are on the developer console
go look at the dashboard for your
projects and you will definitely see if
there's a issue you will see that
surfaced on the dashboard now I'm
curious if I go looking maybe I'm not a
technical or whatever reason I can't
work out what the issue is can I come to
you and say hey look I'm stuck can you
give me some extra information is that
the other thing you will do it yes you
can come and access for more information
we are certain things that we can share
or not share so I stole the X on that we
can we will provide as much information
as you can to help you but you cannot
really show what's going on with your v
for example normally we would recommend
that you kind of the reinstall just to
make sure that you don't you wipe out
any kind of person who may have hacked
into your machine provision your
machines yep quit like the script that
makes sense uh so could you could you
share a little bit of out of your
experience you've been working on this
for quite a while what is some cool
anecdotes of people that have gone
through the abuse process I think the
most common one is I'm not doing
anything I didn't do anything yeah and
then when we talked to them and they'll
go back look at the traffic logs and
they say oh yeah I see this activity it
must have happened because i'm using a
newly installed the software or this
application must be doing it there are
times when people have installed apps
and not even realize that those apps are
doing things on their behalf which is
getting them to violate the terms of
condition and when when you get that
email saying you're violating terms of
service or something is wrong as
suspicious is happening go check it you
may not be doing it someone else might
be doing it from a system there so even
to add on to watch it said sometimes
we've like we've let people know hey we
found that your orbit today like XYZ is
happening on your platform and then
they've come back to us say oh no
nothing's going on wrong everything is
fine and then later on we get like it a
report from a third party also like
saying hey we got a beautiful from this
person and so were mean us an incident
like oh my goodness so something is
wrong what's going on so you know
usually what we do say something is
wrong it is you know try to take a look
because more likely than not there is
something going on and you know that's
kind of and if you're not able to find
that just reply saying hey I'm not able
to find their game your hand interesting
you made an interesting point there very
quickly you work with third parties as
well who was a report like basically the
traffic or something bad is happening in
particular places yes that's correct so
we also received reports from third
parties who are reporting like attacks
that they receive from coming from the
Google cloud platform so it's part of
our duties in addition to like
protecting cloud customers is to also
take that into consideration and
basically what if you verify the report
because not everybody who tells you is
maybe they have like some spiteful stuff
but you have to verify that it actually
is a legitimate report and if it's so we
also act on those
as well cool so what about when people
are hosting content that is a frat ullin
so it's not really about what you are
doing but about what you're serving so
for instance let's imagine like some
private movie or stuff like that yeah
well we all love movies yeah we do so if
someone is bound to be hosting like some
sort of like movie that is copyright
protected or you know cause under the
dmca act what we do when we receive such
reports is that we actually like work
with our legal team and send those
medications to them because that is not
necessarily that abuse but it might be
some typos on at the legal category so
too in basically what we our role in
that is just most like forward those and
to the legal teams that they can move it
from there but there would be a
violation of the terms of service it
will be a luncheon attempt of services
yes interesting and at some point you
mentioned that very often it's about
vulnerabilities and sometimes is up your
applications that are malicious really
but what about when there is something
that all of sudden everybody knows about
and all the all the internet isn't safe
again like a heart bleed for instance
yeah so we in token situations when does
that happen we work a lot closely with
the classic ability to come up with like
some sort of solutions that can help to
protect our customers and kind of like
use that or deploy that to help to
protect them so we've had some
situations like the heartbleed one word
one that comes to mind is one called row
hammer which was like a big security
issue and we work with the class
security team to help us to come up with
appropriate mitigation steps can be
applied on the platform can you expand a
little bit what roja mice I've had never
heard about it I don't know I was not
well we'll put a link in the show notes
oh yeah we'll find it that is just the
one yeah cool yeah so that's cool all
right well I think we should talk about
dockwrath I think yeah elephant in the
room we should probably talk about it um
if anyone hasn't hasn't heard about it
it was Susan yeah very interesting story
basically it went crazy on hacker news
someone said oh yeah google
uh basically shut down my company
completely and I think it's interesting
because it was shut down by cloud abuse
your team so so let's talk about that
what happened could you tell us a little
bit about the internals one act but it
actually happened in there yeah so what
had happened was that we had actually
received like some tea party reports
about attacks coming from the users of
machine and after we independently
verified the situation we send the user
a notification which was a come to the
grace period and so the user did
received a notification but it seems
that there was some problems on the
developer console which prevented the
user from being able to submit a
successful appeal within the time period
that he had and so unfortunately after
the time period had expired he actually
has this product suspended and so that's
when you were to email now it sounds
like there was some some reach app from
the Google cloud team and the cloud
abuse team worked with him so we ended
up getting the project reinstated that's
correct yes and we've been working I
believe with him as well to add to
improvements and basically improve
things that were wrong before can you
talk a little bit lows as well yeah so
that I should actually highlighted a few
things that had been happening all that
were not grateful as far as the
developer experience was concerned and
when this issue highlighted those we've
been working hard to fix them we've made
a few changes to the way we inform
developers on the email as well as the
doubt console so that they have more
information to take me up to take
corrective steps we worked really hard
our team worked really hard to fix those
issues and those were fixed within a
week of this they should happening right
so basically it was the detection was
correct the issue was correct but we
didn't have a good enough experience
from a developer's standpoint but I'm to
like communicate our reach out to us hmm
that always happen it was like a unique
set of circumstances that happened for
him because we do get people who I able
to like successfully appeal but he kind
of like he you know when everything goes
wrong everything goes wrong kind of
consideration so that's opportunity what
what happened in his situation I'm super
happy to say that he is his head
where are we I'm very pleased with the
service overall and will likely remain a
customer for a long time yeah so very
happy to hear that the resolutions made
it made a deep and meaningful impact so
right super happy about that cool well
in case we missed anything I need to ask
our standing question is is there
anything else you want to talk about or
highlight or maybe new things or
anything we might have missed we have a
couple of like help center articles got
basically giving you some explaining
about like some of the policy violations
and also like stepped of how you can
secure your instance so as we see a lot
of times people are compromised so if
you can take a look at those that will
really help you out to kind of like
prevention is better than cure all right
so yeah absolutely our emails will
direct you to those articles so if it is
about just figuring out how to get
through this process we have a Help
Center article on that we have helped
sent articles on specific abuse types
that we will be sending you emails about
we are also trying to proactively reach
out to because one of the things that
we've been talking out a common theme as
the instance has been compromised so
we're trying to reach out to developers
whose instances we see could be at a
high risk of being compromised before
the compromise happens cool so keep
watching out the same for those emails
yeah we'll have we'll have the links to
those articles that are directly from
the show us here so I could say that
then the one of the biggest piece of
advice is pay attention to your emails
go to the dashboard to the dashboard
what could be the second biggest piece
of advice for someone that wants to make
sure that it's not going to get impacted
by fraud um okay to make sure your
instances as a cure you know check your
firewalls a lot of times I loved
everything everything is open to
everybody so it may be it will be easy
to get started faster which is awesome
but blue take extra time that you like I
think to add to that the third one is
like a lot of times the software you
installed on your instance oh just make
sure all the security patches are in
place and keep on top of that so yeah
basically just make sure no one else
gets to use your resources yeah cool
well thank you so much for taking the
time to talk to us about a psu day and
welcome thank you yeah my madness thank
you thanks for joining us today sweaty
and emeka a super interesting disco
and I definitely learned a lot about the
abuse process and why it exists him why
I think it's really so important yeah I
I think that the most important thing
was like you know abuses here only
because we need to protect you too which
is really interesting and how most of
the time when abuse is doing with
customers is because they might have
been compromised so take care I can make
sure that your network is correctly
configured and it's safely like you have
all your networking firewall rules and
all that stuff said correctly which by
the way that's what we will talking
about next episode so maybe that's what
we should do listen to the next episode
next week but I think now it's time to
go talk about the question of the week
and the question of the week is
something that I really like because I'm
a pretty pretty lazy person and
sometimes I see very often example stuff
oh these how you run Jenkins on Cooper
Nettie's or this is how you run I don't
know Drupal or WordPress yeah wordpress
on governor is whatever and and you
really makes me feel like well you know
on Google cloud platform we have these
really cool thing which is the
deployment manager that you can easily
click on a button and then you get a
deployment boom done easy is there such
a thing for Cooper Nerys yeah so this is
this is really cool this is if anyone's
tracked along with what was the point
manager and then helm and then backwards
and forwards anything everything all got
sort of consolidated recently which is
really cool and everything's now in helm
for kubin eighties so helm is this thing
that lets you deploy common things like
applications to communities so some
things that are supported right now in a
stable electro Paul Jenkins wordpress
stuff like that so if you've used
apt-get or you used yum or I don't know
other package managers such as maybe an
MPN or like a gem or something like that
to start it Oh yarn or you I've never
used you on it just wasn't a cerveza
okay okay cool yeah so um then you can
use that to deploy stuff to cure babies
there's a command line client
what it does is it says it has the helm
is the command line client and types are
what's called the packages are called
within within helm and then you can you
can search through it you can utilize
you can go helm install and that builds
stuff up and puts it into communities
for you which is super cool there's
currently two repositories there's the
staple repository and then there's the
incubating repository which has some
stuff that's almost there but not quite
there yet which includes things like at
CD and console and mongodb and a few
other things as well but I think this is
super cool and very exciting for people
who just want to get stuff up and
running on communities especially if
it's common stuff that everyone's
already doing yeah I think that it is is
a very nice voice especially also not
only if you are the one consuming those
packages but if you have a cool
application and you want to distribute
in an easy way that anyone can go like
you know just run this command and get
started trying it yeah absolutely
excellent all right well France asked
are you up to anything interesting in
the next few weeks where are you off to
so I'm gonna be real recording some of
happy thoughts I've just a fungus will
be having some technical issues but I
should be here free releasing some of
those very soon and other than that I
will go next month I will be in Brazil
for go for kommerzielle very excited
about that my talk starts to take shape
which is nice very flex okay so it is
good and then also a gcp next Brazil
which by the way if you're interested in
we're gonna be running our gcp next
conference so Google cloud platform next
you're gonna be learning about what
we're working on and what are the new
things and this time it's going to be in
Brazil in Sao Paulo so November 10
things Sao Paulo if you're somewhere
around we will have a link to that so
you can register it's gonna be lots of
fun there's gonna be a lot of people
from my team and all the teams from
google apart from there so come say hi
awesome that sounds fantastic when this
comes out next week after that I will be
back in a planter again for our web
conference called connect tech and then
the week after that I will be in
Atlantic City for another game
development conference game akan nice
Atlanta again you really like to go to
to the same city twice or three times in
a row I try I try and do that yeah you
know you can also stay there I could you
write no I think I like going there
coming back i think it's just something
right now i'm easy too much otherwise it
yeah exactly alright Fran Cesc well
thank you so much for joining me for yet
another week thank you and talk to you
and your next week see you next week
you
you